hey no I ain't inked well screw you I'll
be running green guy is your Irish all
right that's your solution to everything
will be you guys you're Irish
you started with a basic sword and you
pick up power-ups and weapons on the
ground you'll see them they're obvious
you yeah why are we so many cuz there's
bots so which color are you I know jack
is green where you shot me through the
wall Oh Hank knows how to play I don't
like it my shield didn't work
ow buzzing yo kill me cute you just
gotta keep going for mobbin ha Wow wait
whose organs fear anybody damage no
horse oh yeah boots no that says me
that's kamikaze what happened I'm frozen
for easy thing Erika I'm just fitting up
the bots now oh you guys you guys ow
let's [ __ ] minigun is a piece of [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] that guy
now don't kill me people well laser
beams oh hey hey laser beam yeah
oh he's the brains or something's white
any of us whose way to bond and thing is
a Bioman boy ah damn it
Oh [ __ ] sake man I just got it ha jigs
up to go oh [ __ ] hell
Quadra kill ya I'm only on 40 points
jeez God dang it I keep killing the guy
then next person in line at me shield
down do something about that have to
play the speech game of a medium ah ah
hey I gotcha jag y-yeah at sword yeah oh
yeah fine Kimberly oh oh yeah I need to
get that [ __ ] minigun at least one
can have a jack I didn't mean describe
who's yellow duper you'll never get it
yeah it's amazing I wanted a layer
that's played this before how did I win
what not gonna be [ __ ] laughs let me
do this the bots are actually hard [ __ ]
when they work together so just didn't
know that wait which one I go your your
arrow says your color your arrow says oh
okay oh god I gotta drill all Knights
have drills remember whoops oh we're
going for our flag lunch ah not today
alright who's doing defense I'll do any
friends cuz I have the bow and arrow
I got a medium sword but okay I got it
yeah Oh Harold hornero Boyer couple guys
gonna get it gonna get it done stop dead
sir ah where's our offense team huh I'm
going I'm going
oh [ __ ] what a comment you gotta stop
him
I forget droid men tried it I [ __ ]
try again you sound South African I have
remember and enough about Africa Jack
it's racist yeah you back I got you back
can we go back I am I'm protecting him
yes and I you let him die good job hey
who's it okay laser go for it well go
for it Oh God
I got boots let me take a guess you come
back Oh our [ __ ] the guy he's gonna get
aids in the middle
you should pack up sure let me go it's
got a cap [ __ ] damn it I told you the
the bots are kind of hard
oh wow you murdered us all right I'll
stay Decker defense again I have to flag
bring the flag back oh we I mean I got
minions I got many in school
okay going for grab Hey Oh cheering like
an out crazy hmm
yeah there's a bit of a lag problem in
this game but is it's not terrible I
guess I have the bad guy I'll give you
my back then okay
ah I got him go go oh [ __ ] dog out go
mark a player help me tried you went
ahead of me uh having them all with my
drill it didn't work yeah and I against
get a minions he's so scary
minions are not good yeah you're right
go get it again
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] close me down yeah
I'm the horse slow you down the flag
slows me down that I picked up jack oh
okay oh oh I got a protector ray
yeah oh oh no don't shoot me go go go go
go get him like oh I ran out of juice
oh you got it you got it oh no horsey
get the flag it's fine go go go oh crap
we need to let go together oh [ __ ] why
did you ginger
oh okay now is the perfect chance no
lunch no no there got boy got it
flag stolen I'm coming guys Oh Oh pick
our flag up I can't catch it
there you nice there we are nice yeah
Jyoti I love you guys now we did it oh
okay all right
I cover you here and there I'm going for
it go for it now sting ah how do you get
explosive arrows you get two you pick up
two arrows in a row you level up the
more you pick up cover me oh never mind
you take it he's coming right the flag
ghetto Oh freeze
got him frozen get him get him this guy
right here below my knees and uh where's
our flag oh wow sudden death Oh draw
okay I'm done you almost beat medium
BOTS
Oh
all right what is this okay this is king
of the hill bill just get in the center
go we all against each other now then
probably I'm the king I'm a king yeah
okay let's marry something and help it
out
ah [ __ ] Felix like a little [ __ ] Oh
somebody Boitano this ah
all those points
oh say Oh try to dodge that [ __ ] that's
hard
ah [ __ ] inmate Eddie Sheila good man
bro Oh God oh gosh hey you ready to wake
yeah
wait we are you reach me he makes any
stupid bow and arrow that's the only way
I know how to play
ah oh no no we're saying this is Luther
dirt dirt right oh god no jewelry median
eminence you back back out BAM
I'll just walk out of here
nobody's the king Kamini we do better
Vikki ha ha ha ha ha damn it Oh daughter
oh [ __ ] now many of you even swing at me
my oh ah the cool weapon what's this
thing what is this we'll make it King
hey you weren't even close to me yes I
was you're lagging you gonna bomb I do
snake yeah ha ha ha ha
now I am they personal the slogan Felix
what is this I hear that's what it I
named it up
Phoenix [ __ ] you in your arrows let's
see Jesus bright walk save me
look looks eat eat my minions no way oh
that was caring so badly this isn't fair
my minions
camped in the [ __ ] corner what okay
so if I camp in the corner I'll be
totally I went to the corner one time
Jack come on you can't hit me
that's [ __ ] yeah oh it is I who is
Victor [ __ ] I rat my longer hmm your
wizard Harry
why can't you look No nah not enough my
god the king Oh shun Lee look at him
Ennis he's so fat just like me
yeah you didn't come last oh ho baguette
croissant so what do we do I don't know
now how would I know where there's a
crystal here he ever blue okay
okay nothing happens do we get some
grass like the red ones maybe Troy did
minaret Oh Chad
do you need a drill oh you do need a
drill Oh get away get away
protect your day Wow
oh [ __ ] how do you do wasn't hot they
don't know how you keep drilling
goddamnit are the drills then I usually
Watts keep taking them carve all these
your fault you're a buddy
oh yeah oh yeah that's good drilling oh
yeah you hold it down or something i
think its bam it oh ah that's good
freeze [ __ ] no poor cow 50k yeah
Tina's please yeah yeah booty flyer I
don't like that motors broken back oh
yeah yes no no no no no jack ah god damn
it I'm coming for you hey no it's a jack
[ __ ] DK yoha minions i don't like me
attack my minion get him
oh horsy horse eh oh oh oh that looks
cool oh they were young walked with an
arrow
what hey I'll just go stamping down the
corner guys get it you can't block it
with your gunshots okay okay yes again
in the corner is like per me I dance hip
hip hip yeah
sucks we're never gonna get it off--no
missed come on come on Felix you think
you can play oh yeah alright okay I'm
way too quiet
yeah I broke the shield it Oh
always hit you oh whoa oh yeah oh [ __ ]
mama yeah hi a new rule juggernaut has
stayed towards the middle can't go to
the corner that's fair that's fair
shut up on it you want it in you want it
want it want it baby baby oh yes thanks
oh you might construe you anything for
my baby ah my baby
I kill Joker not a toy Kenya no ha ha
Joker not derd juggernaut saw hog
juggernaut have regret in life wish did
more Joe ganache love are you about that
walking in man what shut up Jack you're
winning what you're winning lose it
Oh Jack sex guy oh oh come on I wasn't
hurting nobody
I was gonna hurt you my good man you
sure Oh No
hey-ya himself feels happy to have
second place I'd like it in the corner
for oh yeah you don't get points over
time oh you only could Oh Gail I said
okay oh yeah oh yes my jack they're both
mine come on mine and we know it's
happening
hang control area oh damn it honey pie
what dirt stay with my I stand with my
cheeks I swear I'm big
oh wow look like bun who are you killing
me I'm Bob how we get kills nobody's
near me don't have me don't hit me bro
don't hit me oh the clampers keeps on
doing Oh believe me believe me X Linux
oh why oh I miss you I'm in Angela Tahoe
we kill them all hahaha no meeting kilo
it's only oh I got him
don't hit me for any like major [ __ ]
lag you guys are never anywhere near me
when you kill me get a minion all I need
is a strong still of a [ __ ] oh wow
thanks for killing each other
shut up hey Mario clear every time man
so John what are you these days you're
gonna forget look at post Phoenix inside
the heat now work a play a minion we
heard nobody I have a 1 and not anymore
ah kill him jacksepticeye minions don't
kill me this is new pages whoa what [ __ ]
and it's a holiday then reset several
weapons
oh come at me I got a [ __ ] huh is that
don't we turn it off here spirit
oh well I've almost got you
Oh No hey hey wait
hey okay if you stay away to me from
like half the [ __ ] map away from me I
hope corners good waiters get it all
right I win by default
yeah come Oh Dan you killed me
no no come on I'm just gonna have fun
out [ __ ] no holy [ __ ] I took out of
the map oh is this thing
don't know don't care good luck this
thing whose did it gbt oh man
one point for every block I brought I
should have taken my kamikaze and just
carved out the entire mountain one by
parts sir
sir Wow triple kill
oh yeah my mm Oh Jackie right last play
hard this cuz people kept killing me for
me half the map away good good have been
better
there's more